great
John that's relative for violence
language content nudity come out Shaw oh
this poor woman whoa oh that is that's
exactly organism Oh aah
[Music]
[Music]
she's down
right here there's Jim Carrey
[Music]
with me
and
drugs
I like that touch of like Kassadin
[Music]
whoa I had security
I loved be here costume play
oh this looks like my kind of a look so
like my kind of film right here yeah
yeah yeah yeah give me weird
desert trippy fever dream be on hit not
again like this is yeah no that's that's
some of my favorite visual style in a
film yeah like there's gonna be a lot of
quiet characters in this movie
yeah I'm intrigued but it doesn't seem
like it's going to be super dialogue
heavy session on the MOA then yeah I
mean girl walked home is like that too
like it definitely takes his time it's
definitely not super verbose I mean
there was you know a good amount of
dialogue so but yeah it's just moods and
Tholian and genres mashed together if
this is anything like that you know if
it's a continuation of what she laid out
in her last film I mean she is she's got
my man
most Suki Waterhouse I never heard of
her but she looks like she's gonna kick
some she really reminds me of like Rose
McGowan character in dry house yeah and
I actually like half everyday to like
interact that poor woman yeah and
nothing I'm drawn to characters like
that in movies women who are like that
or hurt like specimens physical in and
they kind of are on some type of revenge
quest for vengeance mission in some
capacity battling against the odds with
a purpose yeah and clearly getting
shafted along though yeah like setting
them up like they're a victim and then
it become a strong bat out by the end
yeah I'm definitely drawn to characters
like that I'm really curious why they're
not putting Jim Carrey on the on the
credit and stuff maybe he just not
famous I mean we're not I go what
happened there well I wonder yeah I'm
curious because this one way just about
that to the last one you had to point
him out like thinking that might be Jim
Carrey but there was a couple shots were
like definitely Jim Carrey
yeah yeah and I wonder if maybe he's in
a specific interlude or if that
character is just too much to put in the
trailers or something like that like I
wouldn't be surprised if this movie had
characters really like leave it food
movie it seems like there's so much
stuff to show you that they don't have
to get too deep in so at least I'm
hoping that like Jim Carrey gets to do
something really cool it's just they
don't want to give it away too much in
the trailer or something
perhaps it looks like one of the
homeless and in the apocalypse yeah uh
leave that first shot he's like vampire
fangs isn't it exactly what's up with
this dude so yeah I'm very intrigued to
his involvement because it seems like a
real stretch of my characters are
building because this is this looks like
a beautifully shot wonderfully well
captured but rather subdued world of
like some type of post apocalyptic
situation and this is crazy
cute I'm [ __ ] Nino fury road it seems
like rather contain you know like they
got is so fast like the first couple
shots of this trailer woman's like
skateboarding herself and she's a have
your day at NDSU these men who are like
from Venice Beach that can pump in way
to the desert mines in Muscle Beach in
the middle but a juiced-up do this
lifted up tired and Keanu Reeves does
look really cool too
this is it's just that it's just such a
fantastic casting here this is what John
wick does afterwards you know he killed
the whole world and then he whizzed in
this weird this mansion at the end of
time Giovanni Ribisi literally reprising
his role from the movie Ted oh yeah I
actually kind of utter but they only
showed him for a second of a man like
he's good at playing creepy guys who
believe really hard laughs he is so
committed to the point where it's
usually creepy he's great at the weird
he's great at the weirdness but I was
dancing I was thinking of that scene in
Ted with you dancing yeah like this
disease I really liked him but he also
just like I haven't seen him in anything
a long time where he hasn't creeped me
out a little bit I guess how committed
he is to certain thing these are the
kind of movies I think I enjoy most in
the theaters yeah I don't quite know how
to put it like as much as I loved
watching the huge big-budget spectacle
films that are specifically designed to
watch in the movie theater yeah they're
like we watch like beta the Furious
yester
and we'll have a review coming up ribbit
and we watched rated a furious I was
thinking when I was watching it like I
think I could only truly enjoy this in a
fever yeah yeah this is the kind of
movie I could probably enjoy at home but
I feel like I would especially enjoy it
and a big screen it's dark room and you
could just truly absorb the visual
hypnotic experience you know yeah
totally these are fun for me too I think
yeah these are kind of my favorite
things to see in this games because they
still have cool [ __ ] and like hypnotic
visuals and you know it's still
immersive in tone even when there's not
tons of dialogue or sums of action like
movies like these are usually really
engrossing to me when it comes to all
the genre stuff but then also you know
it's more of a film yeah you know so to
me it's the best of all worlds come
together in movies like these worth like
oh there's cool [ __ ] we're also going to
do probably some characters so you get a
little weird philosophical those are my
my favorite theater-going experience and
just when it's a little bit of all those
because like when I saw a girl walk up
along night first time like that was
magic magic I had no idea what to expect
well this looks like a bad batch of all
kinds of bad first person to request
this was mr. yellow for real mr. yellow
for real you are my banana peel you live
only we only live once and it paid off
today because you've got that [ __ ]
shadow subscribe to reject channel
reasons like Ariel Twitter Instagram
click the bell get notified every time
there's new video out on social media
manager facebook.com slash Lum house as
well as the real rejects this is Greg
you can follow us on Twitter and
Instagram while he spills tea all down
your covered it's here I really
committed to this bit